starring in the color purple' yeah very
exciting you're on Broadway that's got
to have been a dream it's been a dream I
even got a Tony nomination I know
absolutely incredible and I've always
thought that must be kind of a cool
almost like romantic lifestyle you're
living in New York City
you're in a Broadway show what are you
doing you are a subway yeah I try to
like stay normal as much as I can so I
still ride the train and like I'll go in
a corner because I don't like to be seen
so I go in a corner like I'm in timeout
like I'm like five years old again so
I'm sitting there with like a hat on
sunglasses and I'm like trying not to be
seen and of course it right but but it
you know it gives me four stats so I
need to go so now do people if let's say
you're on the subway when I lived in New
York City and I would ride the subway
people would always say to me the same
question why are you on the subway I
would say it's the best way to get
around the city
yeah so yeah I get people all the time
like it's weird cuz they're like you you
know see me from across the way and
they're like they'll come and sit beside
me and they're like yeah and that's the
rest of the conversation oh my do you
want a picture like it's really I got
that a lot - you're that girl aren't you
you
you